él es mi abuelo de metros triunfo puros
y débil
mi abuelo nació en 1901 en un pueblo
llamado scope y en el centro de grecia a
dos horas y media aproximadamente de
atenas
mi abuelo es hijo de apóstoles tren
populos de katherine si débil sus
hermanos
panayotis y kris todos sus hermanas a
cilic y georgina
mi abuelo vivió su infancia en skopje y
como podemos suponer en 1901 a 1910
verdaderamente las oportunidades en el
pueblo eran limitadas lo que hacía más
sentido para él en ese contexto era
viajar a la ciudad más importante de
grecia atenas a los 15 años él empieza a
trabajar como cocinero y como mesero y
buscando llevar el sustento a su familia
trabaja en atenas cuando un evento en el
contexto político y social en el que
estaba grecia
entra en conflicto con turquía y se ve
en la necesidad de alistarse del
ejército en la primera guerra mundial
el estando en combate recibe una bala en
su pierna esa bala que recibe en su
pierna en el contexto de la guerra pues
es difícil de tener atención y lo que
sucede aquí es que cuando ella con un
médico lo que le dicen es muy difícil
que te podamos quitar la bala sin que
quede es cojo por lo tanto él finalmente
queda con su bala toda su vida pero a su
vez esto hace que él se retire el
ejército
estando regresando el atenas sigue
trabajando y había un contexto familiar
importante aquí y es que los hermanos
tanto demetrio como cristo como para nos
tenían que trabajar para poder conseguir
la dote con la cual se casarán vasiliki
y georgina el isabel había fallecido de
difteria desde muy joven estando ella
como adolescente entonces a los 28 años
finalmente entre los hermanos se
consigue todo esto y él ya después de
haber cumplido con esa con esa situación
familiar lo que busca él es
oportunidades estamos hablando de una
grecia que se encontraba en una era
posguerra
voltea hacia américa y decide viajar a
méxico encuentra en méxico que existe
cierta afinidad entre los valores y la
cultura griega y los valores y la
cultura mexicana él llega o viaja sin
embargo de atenas del puerto de videos
al puerto de veracruz el aprendiendo 800
palabras en español a través de un
diccionario
y llega a veracruz
y sin tener otro
hay otro
otra otra otra forma de ganarse la vida
empieza es la preparar comida muy pronto
el en ese contexto en el que vivía él en
veracruz decide que hacía más sentido lo
que se llama sentido era viajar a la
ciudad más importante de méxico la
ciudad de mexico
ahí él llega a trabajar como cocinero en
él
centro histórico enfrente el signo
limpia en un restaurant él empieza a ser
un poco de fortuna por ahí y una vez que
hizo fortuna también busca nuevos retos
nuevas oportunidades y voltea hacia el
norte llega aquí a monterrey y en su
estudio de mercado lo que él ve es
sentarse en la plaza de voz y ver
cuántos automóviles del año habían al
ver que no había tantos autos del año y
algunos locales cerrados decidí que la
mejor forma de ganarse la vida es
encontrando oportunidades en torreon
coahuila
él escucha el oro blanco y viaja hacia
la ciudad de torneo
y fundan lo que le llaman el café polo
el café a polo es un espacio una
cafetería que empieza a hacer para él su
emprendimiento y empieza a atender a
personalidades que llegan a la ciudad de
torreón vemos por aquí por ejemplo al
general lázaro cárdenas y básicamente
cuando llegaban gente a torreón se
atendía o se servían ahí mismo del café
en el café a pueblo en un lugar muy
concurrido
el contexto tecnológico que tenía mi
abuelo en ese momento por ejemplo para
hablar con su familia a grecia era pues
prácticamente levanta el teléfono pedir
la llamada y una operadora hacia el
enlace desde el torreón hasta la ciudad
de skopje en grecia y media hora después
le llamaban para decir que el enlace
había sido realizado no era una
comunicación instantánea como lo es
ahora sino que tardaban media hora en
como conectarse en su contexto familiar
nunca se olvida del pueblo y el año el
53 él junto con otras personas aporta
aporta a su pueblo en la escuela que hoy
hoy toda sigue sigue viva sigue viva por
allá
más adelante llega a crear
apolo palacio que son resonantes como
internacional y como que se convierten
como en el punto de referencia allí él
pone él era como el mercado libre a por
su del torreón porque ponía de acuerdo a
compradores y vendedores y de repente de
que haya una comisión por ahí es
importante ese espacio o ese lugar para
ver cómo se desarrollaba muchas del
comercio de la economía que había en la
comarca lagunera el torreón
qué es lo que me inspira de la historia
de abuelo número uno es como él se
mantuvo en movimiento constante una vez
que él viaja de scop y atenas de atenas
a veracruz de veracruz a méxico gméxico
a torreón la realidad es que cada vez
que él se mueve encuentran nuevos
caminos que finalmente forjan sus
decisiones entonces el que se esté
adaptando también a cada uno de los
contextos creo que es digno de admirarse
pero sobre todo es que él jamás regresa
a cada uno de los lugares por donde pasó
siempre fue en constante movimiento de
forma integrante y el cómo llega al
final a hacer lo que fue finalmente lo
lo lo va formando todo todas estas
decisiones que va tomando en el camino
por eso es que es muy importante el cómo
se adaptó el a cada uno de los contextos
el contexto determina gran parte de mis
decisiones y eso y eso creo que es
válido en la historia de mi abuelo pero
también es válido en otras historias
como por ejemplo en la película de solís
y recordarán tom hanks
cuando él logró acuatizar su avión
dentro del río hudson lo que sucede aquí
es que al final salva a todas las
personas pero se le hace un juicio
precisamente porque la compañía de
seguros no quería pagar el daño del
avión y se hace el juicio pensando o
haciendo una simulación por computadora
de cómo debió de haber tomado sus
decisiones y cuando al final de cuentas
dentro del juicio el argumenta que tenía
que ser considerado por humano todas
esas condiciones y deberían agregar el
tiempo que tarda un ser humano en tomar
esas decisiones en base a esa
información finalmente el juicio se
retorna a su favor entonces el contexto
y la forma en cómo pensamos en cómo
reaccionamos nosotros de igual manera
también marca la forma de cómo de cómo
tomamos nuestras decisiones
sabrán o recordarán ustedes la película
de la vida es bella esa película donde
el padre de familia lo que hace con su
hijo es crearle todo un escenario
crearle un contexto un contexto que le
ayudará
alejar su pensamiento de la vida a
través de un campo de concentración de
ahí lo importante que los contextos son
para poder nosotros visualizar lo que
está a nuestro alrededor las
circunstancias que me rodean y cómo
tomamos nuestras decisiones
nosotros es un hecho que podemos
nosotros crear innovación a través de
el conocimiento del contexto de las
personas por ejemplo yo sostengo que
utilizar tirantes los uso y desde hace
muchos años me encanta usar tirantes a
mi usar tirantes para mí es lo más
innovador hay mucha gente que no está de
acuerdo conmigo de que usar tirantes es
innovador yo pero mis tirantes
y sostengo que es innovación porque
porque es un elemento del pasado que
jamás había utilizado me atreví a usarlo
y lo ejecute pero sobre todo me agrega
valor
hay mucha gente que puede estar de
acuerdo y hay gente que no está de
acuerdo pero la gente que argumentamos
que verdaderamente me agrega valor es
precisamente porque tenemos que entender
el contexto en el que estamos los gordos
batallamos para acomodarnos los
pantalones es una condición que si
entiendes el contexto de que yo me
encuentro será mucho más afín se
entenderá que las personas que estamos
gordos y que batallamos para de tener
unos pantalones en su lugar que
batallamos con los cintos que tenemos
que estar comprando cintos continuamente
porque se van rompiendo o porque se van
escondiendo
finalmente entenderemos que esto no
agrega bastante valor entonces si yo
tenía un elemento que no estaba
utilizando lo estoy utilizando ahora y
verdaderamente madre valor eso al final
es innovación la innovación no tiene que
ser tecnología de punto ni tiene que ser
algo demasiado disruptivo
quien diga que no es cierto pruébelo por
favor verdaderamente
les hará le será demasiado útil nosotros
como todas las decisiones necesitamos
nosotros tomamos decisiones con la razón
y con la emoción muchos de los
pensamientos que nosotros tenemos una
vez que ya sabemos que el contexto
determina gran parte de mis decisiones
nosotros creemos nosotros que nuestras
decisiones las pensamos siempre
y mucho y que las tomamos las sesiones
de forma racional
y otras decisiones las tomamos de forma
emocional en los estudios que yo he
hecho dentro de laboratorio innovación
hablando específicamente de servicios
financieros me tomo de cómo tomo como
por ejemplo las decisiones cuando
nosotros las tomamos de una forma
racional es como si los formamos de
forma manual y el sistema que nos
permite tomar decisiones de forma
emocional es como en un piloto
automático para explicar la mejor manera
es como si yo digamos estoy escuchando
que hay un pacto porque hace como pacto
y digo es pacto una persona puede
decirlo de forma racional como es pacto
si hace como pacto si se ve como pacto
si toco las plumas si veo la foto si lo
puedo tocar si lo puedo leer me explico
si hay un pensamiento mucho más racional
cuando me quiero asegurar de todas las
variables que existen para poder decir
esto es pato cuando estoy en piloto
automático simplemente digo así como
pato esparto
en el caso de las de los servicios
financieros cuando nosotros preguntamos
a las personas
de tarjeta de crédito en la que más te
gustaría tener la gran mayoría de las
veces nos dicen es quiero una tarjeta
que sea la más barata pero a su vez
cuando yo le pregunto ese es el
pensamiento racional quiero tarjeta
barata pero cuando les pregunto
verdaderamente cuál es la tarjeta que
tienes sabes cuánto es lo que te está
cobrando a tu tasa que prácticamente
nadie me puede contestar prácticamente
nadie me contesta cuál es la tasa que le
están cobrando nosotros perdemos mucho
tiempo en cosas tal vez que no son tan
relevantes como por ejemplo buscar un
estacionamiento
estoy dispuesto a veces a dedicarle 5 ó
10 minutos en buscar un estacionamiento
te va a costar 15 pesos me quejo de ese
costo de saneamiento pero cuando voy a
tomar la decisión de un crédito
hipotecario que es una relación de 15 20
años es muy difícil
encontramos personas que verdaderamente
hagan ese esfuerzo esfuerzo por pensar
una relación que va a tener con un banco
por 15 por 20 años buscando las mejores
condiciones del mercado
también es cierto que cuando uno le dice
oye con qué banco quisieras trabajar
pues me dicen con el que cobra menos
comisiones con el que de mejor servicio
con el que tenga más cajeros automáticos
con el que tenga más sucursales sí pero
con cuál van con trabajas es que pues es
en donde me pagan es decir yo quiero
de alguna manera cierto que obtener
cierto comportamiento pero por otro lado
lo que estoy recibiendo es una forma de
actuar totalmente distinta
la innovación al final de cuentas se
trata más que crear nuevos productos de
cómo cambiamos los otros comportamientos
como los comportamientos que usamos
nosotros de forma habitual los podemos
orientar a que tengas un comportamiento
financiero más responsable
puedo poner como ejemplo que nos ha
servido mucho el diseño y la economía el
comportamiento para poder nosotros crear
ciertos empujones o ciertas herramientas
que le ayuda a las personas a
comportarse mejor financieramente voy a
poner algunos ejemplos de cómo se crean
contextos en diferentes industrias para
poder nosotros estimular ciertos
comportamientos claramente tiene que ser
la estimulación un elemento positivo y
no un elemento negativo como la
manipulación es decir el uso ético de
este tipo de herramientas nos lleva a
estimular ciertos comportamientos que
son
mejores o positivos para la persona en
lugar de manipular el default por
ejemplo qué pasa con el default el
default les pongo un ejemplo yo hace
como 10 años dejé de fumar y dos años
después me preguntaban cuando ibas
ahorrado por haber dejado de fumar ni un
peso jamás había rompes el que tiene
razón en ese momento creó una cuenta una
cuenta secundaria y entonces programe en
la banca electrónica que me quitara 60
pesos diarios sin dolor sin tener que
hacerlo de forma automática al final del
año tenía 18 mil 250 pesos tiene que
aimar un bono de dosis de 18 mil pesos
al final del año después de programar la
banca electrónica sin dolor de que están
quitando yo no tengo que hacer un
proceso mental ni tengo que ejecutar una
acción cada día para hacerlo
que se hagan automático por de fondo
otro tema que ayuda a que se tomen
decisiones son los social ratings o como
a través de las estrellitas que tiene un
producto muchas personas toman la
decisión de la compra
pocas personas se resisten a un producto
que tenga cinco estrellas 10 mil
calificaciones seguramente lo que piensa
en este producto es bueno
independientemente de la marca sin
cuestionar o sin tomarlo de forma
racional la estructura de decisiones
tengo tres opciones me marca encuadraba
usa más la gente y eso estimula también
a que ya tenga el comportamiento para ir
justamente a elegir alguna es decir
alguien elige por mí otro ejemplo es la
gamificación o el juego cómo podemos a
través de este tipo de herramientas
incitar a ciertos comportamientos a
poblarse muy bien con su sistema de
salud cuando lo que busca es a través de
este juego de marcar con una serie de
círculos o de medios círculos como las
metas de uso de sus del apoyo de su
iphone precisamente para poder mantener
la salud de la persona otro ejemplo es
lemon es lemonade es una compañía de
seguros que es muy reconocida en nueva
york' que utiliza mucho este tema de la
economía el comportamiento para poder
hacer el abordaje de los clientes
la comunicación hace cosas muy
transparentes y evidentemente es una
compañía de la cual tiene un gran
pegador a con sus clientes una gran
vinculación de sus clientes
amazon les voy a platicar de amazon que
amazon no le va hablar de la tienda y es
a todo mundo la conoce tampoco le va a
hablar de la tienda disruptiva que
tienen sea dos donde uno entra toma los
productos y sale con la canasta y se va
y ya le cobro les va hablar de la tienda
que mató amazon barnes and noble una
librería común y corriente
estando en el área de salida de san
francisco entre esta tienda y al
principio uno puede ver que la tienda es
muy similar a lo que tú has visto en
cualquier librería en eeuu tiene sus
libros que son los de negocios y los dos
las categorías de cada uno de los de los
tipos de libros pero luego empieza a ver
que te empieza a vender productos que
tiene a amazon como por ejemplo los los
los kindles empiezas el venta cruzada de
productos después te empieza a decir
bueno los productos más deseados en la
tienda de amazon son estos a bueno si
son los más deseados seguramente les voy
a decir yo también empieza a manejar en
ese contexto ciertas
empujones a que puedas vincularse con
determinados productos otra forma de
cómo ir trata de vincular es dice si te
gusta este libro te gustan alguno de
estos cuatro que te estoy poniendo y eso
lo replica hacen una selección de 10 15
20 libros y te ponen cuatro libros a
cada uno que son similares buscando
también vincular te por ahí
los libros de ficción que son los más
vendidos en el área de la bahía empiezan
a regionalizar no solamente lo que pasa
en la página si lo que pasa en la zona
en donde estoy más aún llega a la calle
en donde estoy los libros más populares
en santana robo en la calle de sant a
larrau en san josé
seguramente si a las personas les gustan
estos libros que están aquí pasando la
calle a mí me van a gustar empieza a ver
esa vinculación cuál es el precio
amazon lo que hace es estos precios que
tú tienes estás viendo por aquí no te
preocupes si tú eres prime base de los
precios más baratos los que están en la
página si no eres prime tengo con el
precio de lista busca que formes parte
de su comunidad
sin duda han hecho las cosas muy bien y
las han hecho muy bien en el online y
ahora en el offline ahora en la tienda
física algunos de los ejemplos que ellos
hacen es estos botones con los cuales
uno facilita la interfaz para que alguno
haga un pedido llega uno y lo coloca en
su cocina o primer botón y
automáticamente se hace un pedido no
funcionaría esto para que podíamos
nosotros hacer un botón para ahorro para
el retiro no funcionaría esto para que
podamos ahorrar para el enganche de mi
casa o sea no podíamos hacer este tipo
de botones que son fáciles de ejecutar
difíciles de sacar modificando estos
contextos que tienen las personas para
que puedan tener comportamientos más
financieramente responsables
sin duda que vemos nosotros el futuro
pues que al final todo esto de la
revolución y todo lo que tiene que ver
con la tecnología más que ver con la
tecnología tiene que ver con la
psicología la siguiente revolución es
más psicológica que tecnológica tenemos
mucha tecnología subutilizada hay que
modificar comportamientos buscar más los
hábitos de uso y menos los hábitos de
compra buscar estimular más los
comportamientos adecuados y el uso de
estas técnicas para poder establecer con
consumos responsables más que necesitar
más tecnología
sin duda hoy lo que nos está pasando es
que tenemos nosotros muchos contextos a
los cuales pertenecemos si hoy en día
las decisiones que estamos tomando
depende de sus contextos y no estamos
contentos con ellas es momento de
cambiar el contexto o mejor aún inventar
un contexto para que mis decisiones sean
mejores
al final creo que lo más importante es
que nunca nunca lo dejemos al azar
muchas gracias
[Aplausos]